whoa
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay what we're doing apparently you
supposed to shove this in here and then
make orange juice oh it's so cute but
why not just buy orange juice maybe this
will be fun great is dab this thing go
stab it Oh got to pop through the bottom
oh this is messy you do this I think I
may have messed up I gotta improvise
you're telling me Japanese children do
this this is a waste of an orange let's
be real here what we got here is a
banana gun the directions are in
Japanese so we don't understand them
there's chocolate in this thing
oh oh you shove the banana up in here
and then I'm gonna give it like a
prostate yeah yeah yeah nothing weird
about this the thing is this is straight
and the banana is never straight now Oh
God ow I'm imagining the banana as a
penis babe gravity oh it's banana
spaghetti Oh taste sexual hello
but why oh my gosh it looks like a pee
hole that's pretty brilliant I get it
this one was with IKEA directions all
right step one open open beer step 2
drinks here what are we the make is
going on here are we gonna make ice
cream India's profits what I just spit
ready yeah why oh my it's overflowing
all of these there have a weird sexual
energy about them do they have a bigger
version if you're having a party this is
taking way too long for just one drink
what the [ __ ] did we just do because I
always go like ah I wish this beer had
more foam boom well it's supposed to be
a slushy beer but either we did it wrong
or why imagine people are doing this
also already after they've been drinking
someone's gonna hurt look Japan has
brought a lot of amazing things
Tamagotchis Pokemon it's unfortunately
just not one of their best innovations
but you know you can try though sorry I
already got the good science
oh I thought I think they're just
yelling at me